let's talk about cataracts which are
actually very common 68 of the
population over 80 years old
have cataracts so it's a big deal and
cataracts are a problem with the lens of
the eye where the lens becomes opaque
and you can't see through it and so
before we get into what to do about it
or how to prevent it or what to do if
you haven't it's very important to
understand what is so unique about this
lens it's actually quite fascinating
it's a piece of tissue that is extremely
robust okay it has no blood supply no
lymphatic system it repairs very very
fast it even has its own unique immune
system it's called immune privilege
which basically makes it less immune
responsive especially to what's going on
to the rest of the body if you have
grafting going on or some type of
transplant of your lens into your eye
it's very unlikely that you're going to
be rejected as compared to getting other
organs donated into your body your
immune system will attack them right
away and so your body really considers
this lens very very important for
survival because if you can't use the
lens and you can't see you don't survive
very well and so the reason why we
probably don't have blood vessels is
because we can't have blood vessels
because they would obstruct our vision
But the lens has a very unique type of
protein that is different from the rest
of the body that is just this
transparent protein and the lens also is
attached to a muscle that allows the
shape of the lens to be changed so this
can affect your ability to see so it
works with the adaptation mechanism to
be able to see far and near the lens of
the eye typically has an incredible
ability to suppress inflammation so why
do we get cataracts the primary reason
is something called glycation okay
glycation is a term to describe the
combining of sugar with a protein or the
combining of sugar with a fat when that
happens in the body this protein becomes
unusable and so the more that this
glycation occurs in the lens of the eye
the more problems you're going to have
and this is why diabetics are way more
at risk for cataracts than the rest of
the population because they constantly
have a higher amount of sugar running
through their bloodstream and so that
tells you right there what kind of diet
you should be on a low sugar low carb
diet there are other factors that
increase the risk of cataracts of course
aging which you really can't do anything
about the chronic use of steroids like
in prednisone things like that if you
think about steroids in general what
that does is that puts your body into a
state where you're going to be using a
lot more sugar so steroids can easily
make you a diabetic because they raise
your blood sugar so that could be the
mechanism with that but also steroids
cause the immune system to be paralyzed
and they shut that down and they get rid
of all inflammation and so that can
negatively affect the person if they
have this chronic exposure to steroids
or even stress because when you go
through stress you have high levels of
cortisol other things like alcohol
smoking and even exposure to microwaves
so if you're cooking with the microwave
and you're looking in the microwave
whoever you're around where that those
microwaves are going at your eye that
can destroy proteins in your lens as
well and the smoking and the alcohol and
the junk foods and the chemicals and all
that over time can create a lot of
oxidation now the lens of the eye has a
lot of protection against oxidation
because it has a lot of antioxidants it
has a tremendous amount of glutathione
so then that brings up this topic of
oxidative stress what is oxidative
stress well you have this imbalance of
too much oxidation or free radical
damage which destroys the molecules of
things and not enough antioxidants when
you have that imbalance then you get
cataracts and of course being a diabetic
or eating a lot of sugar really puts you
in a state of a lot of oxidation
so all that Sugar flowing through the
blood vessels or into the eye creates a
major rusting effect okay or an
oxidation effect based on that
information what can you do well number
one start doing intermittent fasting
immediately okay and that's going to
reduce the glycation effect of that lens
okay number two start to build up this
glutathione start to build up the
antioxidant networks of the body of
course at the same time also limit the
amount of oxidation in things that are
creating free radical damage and that
would be like the smoking the junk food
the exposure to Sugar which I've already
mentioned but as far as these
antioxidants go
to build up glutathione would be very
very smart so how do we increase
glutathione in the body well if you
start eating foods high in Sulfur that's
going to be a big step in the right
direction that would be all the like the
Cabbage the Brussels sprouts the radish
the broccoli all the cruciferous
vegetables and you do want a good
percentage of those vegetables raw
because of the enzymes and antioxidants
which are greatly affected by heat so
with those vegetables the ones that you
can eat raw would be a lot better than
the ones that you're going to steam are
or cook so like big salads with maybe
microgreens or sprouts and other leafy
greens would be very very beneficial
because the leafy greens also contain
lutein and zeaxanthin which are two very
powerful phytonutrients to help not only
prevent
cataracts but also macular degeneration
lutein and zeaxanthin also is in egg
yolks okay so egg yolks are really
important too but the Deep leafy green
vegetables are very important to build
that up as well as building up your
glutathione some other things that will
help you build up glutathione are
selenium vitamin C vitamin E zinc and
another compound called NAC
which helps glutathione be replenished
so the question is going to be well are
these remedies going to actually cure
and the answer is it really depends it
depends how bad it is how long you've
had it
uh your repair mechanisms
but it can't hurt and uh if you take it
it doesn't work at least it's not going
to create side effects maybe you can
create benefits in other parts of your
body but the point is I'm trying to give
you the big idea of the mechanism what
you should start eating on a regular
basis what you should start including in
your supplements and a greater
understanding what causes this problem
in the first place now there's two other
vitamins that are also very important
and I've talked about these in other
videos B1 which is thiamine and vitamin
B2 which is riboflavin and these two
vitamins also not only act as an
antioxidant but they found that if
you're deficient in these two vitamins
your risk for getting cataracts are much
greater now since we're on the topic of
antioxidants and oxidation and glycation
if you haven't seen this video on what
to eat to actually minimize this
glycation from your blood sugars I put
that video up right here check it out